here right now with more Fox News
contributor former Speaker of the House
Newt Gingrich Mr Speaker I think that
Bolton tape says everything we need to
hear from John Bolton your reaction I
think first of all they're going to go
down a total down dead alley because the
president's going to impose executive
privilege they would then have to go to
court so if they want to drag this out
another month or two they have an
opportunity to do it but it would be
pretty stupid the country's already
opposed to dragging it out the country
said it's over David Axelrod who was a
very key person for Barack Obama that
had a recent column and said he sat
through a focus group of Democrats in
Chicago and it was 80 minutes 8 0
minutes before any of them mentioned the
impeachment at which point everybody in
the group said that's over it's not
going to happen I don't want to talk
about it and axel writes that Democrats
need to understand this is not working
the Democrats ought to be voting to have
no more witnesses the Democrats frankly
on a vote to acquit and close it down
tomorrow every day this goes on the
Democrats look smaller more political
more destructive of America and I think
that there's no reason to have any more
witnesses because there's no case this
literally there is no case here you know
if Jay Sekulow said today mr. speaker
and the Clinton impeachment proceeding
the witnesses that actually gave
deposition testimony were witnesses that
had either been interviewed by
deposition in the house proceedings
grand jury proceedings and it was
specifically you know those same people
knew witnesses were not being called why
would any Republican in the Senate want
to break that precedent ok I don't think
there's any real reason to have any new
people come in that violates the whole
point this is not an inquiry into what
happened in Ukraine this is an
impeachment trial in an impeachment
trial there's a very simple question are
the allegations rising to
level that you would deprive the
American people of the person they
elected as president now I don't think a
single one or the Republicans believes
the Donald Trump is going to be
convicted so I think it is an absolute
game for any of them to vote yes to have
more witnesses because the witnesses
aren't going to change anything this is
not an impeachable offense we have a
very good way of solving it it's called
an election as you pointed out in 279
days the real jury the American people
will get to decide my hunch is they're
going to reelect Trump by an amazing
margin but what Schiff said the other
day was very chilling he said we can't
let this up to the voters because he's
such an arrogant elitist he thinks he's
more important than the American people
and that's what's at stake here and I
would hope that after they think about
it that not a single Republican will
vote to have any more witnesses let me
ship actually said today not all quid
pro quos are the same nobody's as bad as
Joe I'd add but he said some
illegitimate corrupt you don't need to
be a mind reader for one you can ask
John Bolton I want to replay what Bolton
said about the president's conversations
with President Solinsky he sounds just
like the way Donald Trump described him
warm cordial and they were
congratulatory and he and the president
spoken twice and well let me let me let
me play this tape because I think this
is all we need to hear from John Bolton
I will be meeting President zalenski he
and President Trump have already spoken
twice President called to congratulate
President Solinsky on his election and
then on his success in the parliamentary
election they were very warm and cordial
calls we're hoping that they'll be able
to meet in Warsaw and have a few minutes
together because the success of Ukraine
maintaining its freedom its system of
representative government a free market
economy free of corruption and dealing
with the problems of the Donbass and the
Crimea are
high priorities here obviously but high
priorities for the United States as well
and he said mr. speaker free of
corruption and he saw nothing wrong with
the call there is very clear and the
four facts never change
maybe whatever Donald Trump said they
did nothing they announced nothing he
didn't ask them to do anything because
they told us he didn't ask for anything
why are we even here well we shouldn't
be here that that's the whole point I
think that there was a pretty good
grounds for having the Senate literally
reject the entire proposal the day it
came across and I thought the arrogance
of the dishonesty of both chef and
Nadler in lecturing the senators on what
their duty was which by the way is about
as dumb a thing you can do as insult the
jury which is what they did and I think
that the result has been that they've
even further alienated the Republican
senators and I think they have now
weakened their position with a number of
other Democrats I wouldn't be at all
surprised to see a bipartisan majority
not just Republicans but a number of
Democrats vote that the president's not
guilty it's not impeachable I don't
think it's in their best interest to do
so mr. speaker as always thank you for
being with us